todos vocês estão vendo essa animação só
que alguns de vocês podem ver nessa
animação no sentido horário
em outro sentido anti horário o euro
sentidos correta
já viram né já mudou essa orientação não
joga lá e agora que tem um movimento
certo
a orientação certa e agora que vocês
acham
então essa movimentação essa orientação
não é uma das formas que o gosto de
mostrar a cara de vida é um indivíduo é
aquela pessoa é uma pessoa que nós
enxergamos um monte de uma forma
diferente
noventa por cento das pessoas no mundo
inteiro estão estressados nem como
provavelmente alguns de vocês né e no
meu caso também um professor final do
semestre é ter um nível de stress e as
tecnologias têm contribuído né pra esse
stress outro lado será que essas novas
tecnologias também pode contribuir para
melhorar a vida das pessoas
nos últimos anos a gente vem realizando
pesquisas nessa área que a variabilidade
da freqüência cardíaca
quanto maior essa variação entre
batimento e outro né menor stress menor
variação maior estréia então é isso que
a gente vem estudando o que vocês estão
vendo a ali na primeira o normal não é
quanto maior essa variação está
tranqüilo ali no meio na pessoa
estressada tem pouca variação entre o
abatimento e outro e aí a pessoa que faz
uma respiração inspiração e expiração é
menor
o stress e essa tecnologia que a gente
vem utilizando nas nossas pesquisas
porém é uma tecnologia não é cara e não
é qualquer pessoa que pode adquirir essa
tecnologia então não é por mais que essa
tecnologia mostra nem os benefícios mas
é uma tecnologia cara
ou será que tem volta tecnologia
pode ajudar as pessoas milhares de
pessoas
essa é uma tecnologia é uma cinta
transmissor do batimento cardíaco e um
fone de ouvido passado
essa sim de curso na faixa de 70 e 80
reais e foi direito pois vocês têm
através do fome né e assim tem o
computador
nós podemos ter um monitor ao batimento
cardíaco todos vocês tiver uma cinta
onde o mesmo computador
respondi uma literal estreia de vocês
estiveram estranhos pode aumentar essa
variação entre o batimento e outro em
software online está disponível
gratuitamente e atrás de si só nós
podemos monitorar o batimento cardíaco e
conseqüentemente é monitor ao stress até
essa tecnologia não é cara que não é
qualquer pessoa que pode comprar tem
assim tanta que também nem 70 e 80 reais
mas só que tem outro tecnologia ou que é
poderia ser bem barato e acessível para
milhões de pessoas assim nós
desenvolvamos o fã do programa
então é uma tampinha bambu balão um tubo
de látex e microfone eu poderia conectar
esse microfone
tá certo nessa campanha e manter o meu
batimento cardíaco
eu poderia não ter feito isso ele está
escutando a mora o meu batimento
cardíaco
usando essas tecnologias essa tecnologia
está com menos de dez reais dependendo
do microfone pelo do touro custa menos
de 10 reais e 5 reais 7 reais
e aí nós validamos através de uma cinta
um era tarde o grama e o fonograma nós
podemos neve que é exato é o valor do
batimento cardíaco e um
eletrocardiograma e o nosso foi no
programa não é bem próximo ao
equipamento que custa bem caro
através do fone código não me custa
menos de dez reais e milhões de pessoas
tenham um computador e o software ios a
nós podemos então
através da respiração diminui o stress
porém mais estudos mostrando que através
da respiração monitoramento batimento
cardíaco
nós podemos diminuir a depressão a
pressão arterial entre outros não é
problema da saúde mental que aflige
milhões de pessoas
por que vocês têm ostentas cobre
digitalks meca funcionários utilizam e
temos o nosso aqui é o estetoscópio
digital sem fio é que essa tecnologia
porque mais cara mas estou vendo aqui o
sinal através do fone no programa e um
microfone sem fio a qualidade de sinal
do som do batimento cativo e aí nós
podemos estudar ainda a morfologia de
batimento cardíaco há aqui vocês estão
vendo dois locais diferentes com dois
tipos de som do batimento cardíaco está
a o computador não é você não pode levar
um computador pode estar levando o
netbook mas muitos locais você não
consegue levar não têm acesso nem muito
difícil utilizando qualquer lugar que
você tivesse três a mais que nós podemos
estar utilizando as novas tecnologias
o smartphone ou na então hoje dois
milhões de pessoas tem smartphone ou
qualquer pessoa que tiver o smartphone
será que dá para monitorar o batimento
cativo diminui o stress utilizando a
mesma tecnologia né assinto foi de um
vídeo o diferencial este clube 37 que o
e3 qualquer um de vocês tiver uma sinto
fome todos vocês têm esse pt 3 custasse
80 centavos
o smartphone é só com o lugar e vocês
vão ter esse monitoramento batimento
cardíaco em qualquer lugar e vê seu
batimento cardíaco tem outra variação no
nível de stress neto vão aumentar
utilizando a respiração quando a gente
desenvolver esse aplicativo curso então
quem tiver um smartphone é e o android
você já pode baixar e poder testar é
esse o nosso aplicativo e também está é
verificar o nível de stress de vocês
não é o microfone até um fone de ouvido
uma tampinha dois balões não poderia
funcionar como fã do programa
paulo principalmente acharam estranho eu
conheci essa tecnologia que no pescoço
está sendo o que você está vendo aqui é
um fã no programa tá é só com dar né
esse fone acerta isso microfone e vocês
vão conseguir monitorar o batimento
katyn
e essa tecnologia está quanto é uma
tampinha e dois balões né provavelmente
menos de um real a partir de desta
tecnologia nec ó considera sofisticado
em função de um smartphone
vocês podem monitorar o batimento
cardíaco na e consequentemente bonito ao
estresse depressão a pressão arterial
através do nosso aplicativo não nos
podemos então utiliza uma tampinha hoje
está desenvolvendo né esse aplicativo eo
os testes mostrando que sim a tampinha
né só é só um microfone conectar colocar
a mão que ele já pega o batimento
cantinho
hoje o aplicativo os dois bilhões de
pessoas com smartphone ea tendência é
aumentar significativamente os próximos
35 anos
o nome de pessoas que vão ter um
smartphone nos nossos trabalhos nos
nossos objetivos aqui através do
smartphone não importa nem a classe
econômica das pessoas nós podemos salvar
a vida das pessoas é uma das que eu
adoro fazer por isso que estou aqui mas
formalmente adoro criar né adoro
inventar
'nesse tiver ocioso né não consegue
ficar quieto mas não consegue ficar
parado então nosso trabalho que é
descobrir meios nem e acessíveis a
qualquer pessoa e não objeto
biotecnologia principal é um smartphone
é tudo que esteja ligado ao smartphone
voltado e se desenvolvendo e vai ser
tudo de graça